I can't really tell you how to do it I  can undescribed how I D find somewhere  comfortable rest your eyes concentrate  on your breathing  to all that exists  however I wish to coasters  so astral projection allows you to  contact spirits who aren't in our world  I don't think you should be messing  around with that why exactly you want to  try I only wanted to look into that  world on my mark  your mother is not scamming but  something else is filming see if you  could actually do something in the room  as to attempt number two it doesn't make  any sense  surely you can record your own spirit  it felt like a dream but he was so you  believe everything you're about to see  in city I believe the paranormal  you put something here with you  [Music]  you